reject everyone I am Ashley and I am
from Queens actually a neighborhood
called Ridgewood two blocks over from
Brooklyn I actually walked between the
border every day I have some slides here
if you'd like to follow along I
recommend writing it down just because
I'm about to quote a lot of people and
so the reading list for this is well
documented in the slides and I suggest
that you check it out
so yeah hi I'm a g-dubs you might know
me from Twitter where I'm very prolific
I don't recommend you follow me
I always apologize when I hear that
happen so wouldn't do it so I'm from the
United States but I like to say that
these are more of my red white and blue
I took these pictures when I was in
cologne this is actually my second trip
to Germany this month which is pretty
cool because I really really really like
it here oh this is something I treated
you guys are really awesome and I really
really dig it so yeah I am a software
engineer at the Mozilla Foundation and
you guys might have gone upstairs if you
haven't check it out and at the end of
this talk there's a chance that you
might be able to get some swag from them
they've got some really cool swag and I
have some for you alright so at the
Mozilla Foundation a lot of people don't
really know exactly what we do but the
way we talk about our mission is that we
want to foster universal open web
literacy and so that's kind of a
mouthful but the idea is that we really
want people to be ethical consumers and
creators on the web and that can be a
lot and I'm not going to really dive
into almost any of that but it's a cause
that's important to me instead what I'm
gonna say is for me this means I like to
think about thinking especially the type
of thinking that happens when people
write code and this kind of idea of mine
my goal leads me to do projects like
this where I take the idea of how people
take things apart and try and create new
learning tools for them and you're gonna
hear throughout this
talk that I care a lot about learning
tools and I actually kind of think
everything is a learning tool so what's
my talk about who knows maybe we should
just talk about cows in space right
that's why you guys are here right to
hear about cousin space no all right
well some people have talked about art
maybe we can talk about art this is some
cool art that I found on the Internet
full of cool art uh but yeah maybe maybe
we'll talk about JavaScript right
JavaScript and maybe in more particular
we'll talk about es6 right yes six all
right but what you're gonna find and
hopefully this doesn't disappoint you
but this talk is all about a lot more
than es6 and so I'm gonna start off by
talking about the idea of abstraction
all right
cows in space though maintain that so
this wouldn't be a good talk if I didn't
quote Dijkstra right this is again a
good computer scientist would say and
here he defines abstraction he says the
effective exploitation of his kind of a
bad pronoun let's say their prows of
abstraction must be regarded as one of
the most vital activities of a competent
programmer I didn't turn my phone off
whoops all right so again what we're
seeing here right is that when we are
doing programming in its most
fundamental we are abstracting so the
abstraction principle is defined by
Benjamin C Pearson one of his most
foundational books called types and
programming languages and if you haven't
read it you should check it out but here
he says each significant piece of
functionality in a program should be
implemented in just one place in the
source code where similar functions are
carried out by distinct pieces of code
it is generally beneficial to combine
them into one by abstracting out the
varying parts and this should be
something that we're probably really
familiar with as developers for me this
is actually the joy of developing I love
refactoring things I love this feeling
of abstraction but I want to take this
idea and take it a step
there I want to get a little bit maybe
more academic or theoretical with it and
so to do that I obviously went to
Wikipedia which is definitely the
academic source here it says abstraction
tries to factor out details from a
common pattern so that programmers can
work close to the level of human thought
pause on that close to the level of
human thought we're gonna come back to
this but that's pretty questionable all
right so we're close to the level of
human thought leaving out details which
matter in practice but are immaterial to
the problem being solved we're gonna
flag that too in material to the problem
being solved we've got danger danger all
right keep this in mind as we continue
alright so another little anecdote uh I
was the lead instructor at a boot camp
program in Brooklyn and if you have
questions about boot camps I understand
but this one was awesome basically
really took people who had never
programmed before but also were
unemployed so you had to meet a certain
criteria and then over the six months we
taught them to become developers and we
also got them jobs and so this was a
really really great program and it's
still funded today it's called the New
York City web development fellowship but
more important I think is that this is
really where I began to understand that
teaching was one of the fundamental
skills that a developer needs and so
about a week before I was going to start
I was at a Ruby user group with the Dean
of the school and he was talking about
how great Ruby is as a development
language it was designed to be read as
if it was spoken by a human being
consequently it is in English and this
was by a Japanese person which is
extremely complicated but either way
what he said was he's like look at this
Ruby each loop even your mom could
understand that sidebar that's not okay
moms are smart and cool do not be rude
all right
so you're looking at this and you're
saying oh Ruby is so great and though
you might be getting the sinking
mission that I don't agree with him I
will say that at the core he had a
really important thing to say all right
JavaScript maybe too much punctuation he
is saying programs must be written for
people to read and only incidentally for
machines to execute and this is a really
important thing to understand all right
the people who are interfacing with your
code are primarily people the computers
involved are kind of over here the
people maintaining it the people using
it the people writing it all right they
are the people interacting and you have
to realize that they are not computers
but the idea of people being able to
read something is tough this is my door
in Queens and you can see here I wrote
some notes and then you can see down
here the UPS person saying nope we miss
you and we could not open the door so
again understanding what the level of
human thought is what people can read
and understand is a tricky thing
so another anecdote and as you may have
guessed I am NOT going to come out on
Ruby's side here so I was sitting at my
computer and my assistant instructor was
sitting in front of the class and he was
teaching iteration all right iteration
is hard for beginners and I could hear
just through the one side of my
headphones it was not going well at all
and this has been going on for a while
and so if any of you guys know me I
decided to do something bold and that's
quite in my nature
and so what I did is I interrupted the
class and I said hey I'd like you for a
second to ignore all of the Ruby you
just learned this probably shouldn't be
hard because you're extremely irritated
and frustrated with it right now and
then what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
teach you iteration using a language you
don't know and they're like that sounds
like a bad idea like I know I know but
look just let me try this is already
kind of terrible let's let's just roll
with it and so that's exactly what I did
what I'd like to point out here is we
understand that the concept of iteration
is really three concepts state condition
increment in that Ruby
that's all hidden away inside that
keyword each but in the JavaScript I can
point to it right there because it was
exposed by the syntax the developers
that I were teaching were able to see
that and it could feel more control over
it all right it exposed the underlying
concepts that the abstraction hid away
and as experienced developers we love
that it's in a way but beginners hate it
it's very very confusing it's this idea
of magic which sometimes we think is
good for beginners but it turns out that
it's not all right so my secret
physicist boyfriend Richard 5-minutes
has something to say about this a bit he
says the real problem in speech is not
precise language the problem is clear
language it is really quite impossible
to say anything with absolute precision
unless that thing is so abstracted from
the real world as to not represent any
real thing and so remember with Ruby we
were trying to be real we're trying to
be human language all right and so we
have these kinds of dichotomies that we
run into the desire to be precise but
also the desire to be clear and at the
same time we also want to be abstract
because we don't want to be writing out
everything but there's also a desire to
map things towards reality so they're
easier to reason about all right and so
Pablo Picasso kind of leads us in a
direction he says there is no abstract
art you must always start with something
afterward you can remove all traces of
reality so we kind of have an origin
problem here when we're designing
programming languages where do we start
on the edges of these dichotomies all
right
this is my favorite slide from every
conference talk ever you may have seen
it already but what I want to imply is
with programming languages
we're often doing this to our developers
all right so if you can't read it it
says how did
an owl draw some circles draw the rest
of the [ __ ] owl that is the only
curse word in this talk unless I mess up
alright so but we need to understand is
both of these instructions and the
instructions themselves are terrible
this is no good
alright we're in this kind of lock all
right and this is all this is from
Brooklyn not Queens
so you can kind of be right all right
we're stuck here and so hopefully some
of you got the reference the clickbait
enos of my title which is i'm going to
be walking you through a little bit of
some Carl Sagan all right and he says
when we're doing this we need to think
about thinking all right and for him he
says the journey starts here so let's
talk about cousin space right yeah you
guys remember that cows in space from
our man Pablo Picasso all right all
right so when we think about thinking we
need to know humans are amazing at
pattern recognition we're able to look
at something like this and see this you
see it right now well someone saw and
convinced everyone because that we have
this right a cow in space so we need to
realize when we do this pattern
recognition all right we recognize
patterns and when we name them we're
building our abstractions now this is a
very dangerous activity because bad
abstractions are probably one of the
most dangerous things out there so you
might be familiar with horoscopes the
entire field of cosmology has come out
of this all right and people spend so
much time and money and worrying about
it this is my horoscope from today maybe
it's right I don't know maybe I'm wrong
about this being a false abstraction I
also had this one which told me that I
have nothing to worry about you guys are
charming so we'll see how that works out
all right so what I'm trying to say here
is that when you're recognizing patterns
building abstractions paving the cow
paths
yes I'm sticking with this meadow
or we need to be very careful all right
because again bad abstractions are
extremely dangerous so now let's talk
about JavaScript
alright javascript has been a delightful
beginning programming language because
it has left a lot of abstractions and
that's all about to change so September
28th 1980 is when JavaScript was
invented come on guys really that's not
true all right no that's when they show
cosmos came out and again this was by
Carl Sagan and the key to this show was
to make available the underlying
scientific concepts that ruled our
universe make that available to the
layperson and this was extremely
important all right and in doing so he
kind of had this catchphrase where he
said if you wish to make an apple pie
from scratch you must first invent the
universe and it has to say that to
really understand what's going on in our
world understanding the fundamental
concept is extremely important I heard
this and I was like yes this is the
issue we have at es6
oh yeah by the way I'm not gonna say
that he has 6 2015 thing if you get
upset about that I don't care all right
so this was a girl say again this is
actually me but I'd like to think that
he supports this cause all right so
let's talk about es6 alright so as Gina
mentioned we're gonna read some of the
spec now yay all right so Ekman script
syntax is relaxed to enable it to serve
as an easy to use scripting language now
relaxing is cool I love being in Germany
I like relaxing around here have some
beers but it's not always the right
message that's a real thing that was a
first message on the OkCupid dating app
all right is is relaxation really the
problem that JavaScript is trying to
solve is were there not enough relaxing
languages out there and so we have
JavaScript now probably not right so
what problem is JavaScript trying to
solve like well Java scripts legacy be
and we look back at it as this like
strange artifact from computer science
and that's a really heavy question and I
don't really know the answer but I think
it's gonna have something to do with
this alright and this is Laurie Voss CTO
of NPM and he says fundamentally it's
hard to think of a compelling reason a
brand new web dev would learn two
languages when they can just learn
JavaScript now that might sound pretty
controversial they follow up by saying
if I could pick any language in the
world to use them both the server and
the client it might not be JavaScript
but we don't get to pick so let's think
about that and then we'll talk about
equity script six classes you can tell
what I'm gonna say right robot there all
right so sugar makes me sick but like
literally it makes me sick I have type 1
diabetes but also syntactic sugar makes
me nervous and spectacular sugar makes
me nervous because again we see that
syntax always obfuscates these
underlying concepts so back to the spec
even though Ekman script includes syntax
for class definitions Ekman script
objects are not fundamentally
class-based alright so you might not
need class syntax alright so this is a
man who if any if you take anything out
of this talk take this away he says
remember that all models are wrong the
practical question is how wrong do they
have to be to not be useful what that's
it in all right so how wrong are we all
right so in a class-based
object-oriented language in general
state is carried by instances methods
are carried by classes and inheritance
is only if structure and behavior in
ACMA script the state and methods are
carried by objects well structure
behavior and state are all inherited
all right so that might be a little bit
difficult to parse if you've never read
this before I really dealt with them
so I'm gonna use a blog post by this guy
named Regan Walt who I'm gonna shout out
for being awesome for saying stuff like
this
he wrote a blog post called prototypes
or not classes where basically and I
won't read this to you he explains the
idea that classes are described as often
as boiler plates all right their
blueprints the class is the blueprint
and then we make a house from it all
right and the house is the object but
that's not true with es6 JavaScript
classes are model homes the idea here is
that you have a model home and you can
build a house based on it and you could
leave the model home empty but someone
could move in I mean that since things
get a little tricky all right so what we
understand here is that we have a syntax
that cloak lis really Optus gates the
underlying functionality all right and
so you might be thinking that I'm saying
you know you know Java Cooper classes
are their objects there they're not
classes really and maybe go home tc39
you're drunk
this is me and that is ginger ale all
right but no that's not what I'm saying
at all I'm saying this is not a hate
talk in any way shape or form instead
what I'm hoping to suggest here is that
we take a different perspective when
we're evaluating new features for
language and that that perspective is
the educational one and so I do want to
mention just briefly all right that you
could easily shut me down by being with
what even is a class is that even
defined and I'd be like meet me
afterwards and we can talk about this
this language which introduced them it
is super super awesome all right so you
might be thinking that I'm trying to why
wage class warfare because I told you I
was an anarchist right this is near my
apartment here that's a real thing I
don't even want to deal with that all
right but instead what I'm trying to say
is that JavaScript might be trying to do
a lot of things and not be any of them
if you ever go to Penn Station this is
by Madison Square Garden it wasn't open
when I took the picture but I intend to
return yeah so uh listen the glam Boy
has this amazing talk called syncing for
programmers and in this talk he says
writing is nature's way of letting you
know how sloppy your thinking is and so
I like to take that and I say teaching
is nature's way of letting you know how
sloppy your understanding is how many
people in here have ever taught
programming everyone who has their hand
down do it it is by far the own like one
of the best ways to improve your
programming skills all right so those
fancy people who are talking about
programming needing to be able to be
read by humans they wrote this amazing
book all right and this is a huge change
in computer science education what they
said is we need to be teaching
programming concepts not language
features when we're programming we need
to understand the activities the
abstractions that we're building not
where to put a semicolon all right
and this is super important when we
think about the idea that we have
programming concepts that conflict with
our syntax in JavaScript JavaScript will
be the introduction to programming
concepts for an entire generation of
developers whether we like it or not and
so we need to be cognizant of this idea
and 2.2 miles this talk we need to be
empathetic of our users our JavaScript
users which is going to be people
learning programming all right we need
to be thinking about the problem that's
being solved and oftentimes the problem
that JavaScript is solving is teaching
people how to program so to follow up
that book sicp written by Abelson and
Sussman was this excellent person named
peter van roy and so what I'm not trying
to say is that these new features are
making JavaScript a terrible programming
language but something a little bit
different so he came up with this book
that followed it up and he said we need
to teach programming as a unified
discipline
the way he did that in his class all
right was to talk about programming
languages as tools programming languages
solve problems the solutions that they
provide combined with those problems all
right to be paradigms and so perverting
the images are able to do well at one
programming paradigm sometimes they do
better at others but there's not
necessarily any bad programming language
all right and so when he taught his
classes he would insist that people
start from the beginning to invent the
universe you might say and what he did
is he had them build an entire kernel
and he says a good way to organize a
programming course is to start with a
simple language and then to extend this
language gradually so I'm obviously
saying all right we must invent the
universe when we teach programming we
need to make sure that we teach the
underlying concepts before we teach the
abstractions you need to feel the pain
before you know how do you use that tool
all right so obviously every beginner
sure at a current language right this is
a really terrible idea no one should
ever do that unless yeah just no all
right but what we can take from this is
this idea of creative extension all
right and we actually are kind of
familiar with this all right Ron
Jeffries who did extreme programming
every know if that's a thing anymore but
this is something that we know always
implement things when you actually need
them never when you just foresee that
you need them don't pre optimize all
right so what we need to know is that
prototypal inheritance is a big part of
the JavaScript universe we might think
classes are useful but they're not good
for teaching and we should not start
with them all right this is how the
apple pie gets made vegan-friendly
metaphors all right so this is a tldr
slide so if you go back as a teacher I
always kind of like giving an index for
my points all right but what I'm trying
to say is that when we look at
programming languages we need to be
empathetic to our audience and we also
need to understand that abstraction is a
difficult thing for beginners all right
and that no matter what we do with our
language when we teach we need to start
at the beginning and now I'm going to
take the last five minutes I have to
kind of put you guys on call
because I have this kind of kumbaya
question right what do we even mean when
we talk about programming right so this
is one of my favorite philosophers
Martin Heidegger and you wrote this book
called what is called thinking which is
a very bad translation of a German that
I'm not entirely sure how to pronounce
either but in it he says this the most
thought-provoking thing in our
thought-provoking time is that we are
still not thinking and you might see
where I'm going with this because I'm
gonna ask are we programming yet when we
look at the JavaScript language remember
the Dijkstra said abstraction is at the
core do you feel like that's what you
spend most of your time doing or is it
just lint is it I miss the semicolon all
right
a lot of people like to think that
things that are difficult like C++
alright is made to be difficult to make
sure that you're a good programmer and
doing it right but I don't think that's
a good idea at all all right there are
people in the Academy who are taking
this idea seriously and really trying to
think about what programming should be
and as they design languages designing
for that all right and it's frustrating
to me because this seems to only be
happening in the Academy like MIT with
scratch why are we not looking at that
in the industry and I think it's
something that we should be doing so
Thomas Kuhn is a philosopher and a
scientist and you wrote in this great
book the structure of scientific
revolutions that scientists worked for
models acquired through education and
through subsequent exposure to
literature often without quite knowing
or needing to know what characteristics
have given these models the status of
community paradigms why do we want
classes are we sure that's the right
thing or did just Ruby do it and a bunch
of other people did it and now we've
decided that we need to catch up is that
the perspective we really should be
taking so we have an awesome opportunity
to more radically think
about how we extend JavaScript all right
we can think more radically about how we
build the abstractions and which ones we
want to build all right I'll leave you
with this Carl Sagan says it is far
better to grasp the universe as it
really is than to persist in delusion
however satisfying and reassuring so I
ask you reconsider your ontology think
about it a lot is this the language of
these the abstractions that we need and
always stay a beginner thank you
all right
all right I have a final thing and I
always like to take this back to my
students because as I said this is where
I've learned everything they have built
a kind of silly website called clap for
Ashley and if you tweet at this hashtag
it will pop up and clap but I asked and
as I mentioned the Mozilla swag before
if you could tweet something about how
you're going to stay a beginner or
commit yourself to teaching other
beginners we've got some really cool
Mozilla bags that I will hand out to
people who tweet great stuff so again
thank you and I'll leave this here if
anybody wants to dive in assuming that
the internet works this is always
awkward cuz it's like no one's clapping
for me I understand it might be broken
okay